good morning you guys it's cold outside
everybody get a nice warm coat hey what
i think some texas came back there so a
nice warm coat it is cold for sure we've
got lots of temperatures very close to
freezing now as we're getting uh close
to that sunrise is on its way up finally
this is the point where we hit our
coldest temperatures of the morning and
then they can finally start going back
up so you're freezing out in the lake
set out in summerlin 36 on the strip
look at those 20s at mountain's edge
below freezing in seven hills it is
another cold cold morning teens up there
at kyle canyon 22 right now at red rock
aleonte you're at freezing as well
single digits again up there in ely and
over into cedar city in southwest utah
should be a nice weekend if you wanted
to head up to zion or maybe cedar city
and brian head to bryce canyon beautiful
for the weekend
our local mountains will be looking for
a little extra wind as we get into
saturday and sunday but today should be
fine freezing in mesquite 20's at indian
springs 28 in prompt and there's still
northeasterly wind for laughlin right
now at 46 degrees these are all wind
wind chill advisories as well as still
some winter weather advisories for texas
they've got truckers stuck on i-10 in
west texas with the ice-coated roads
there and this big winter storm is now
headed for the northeast with rain out
on the east coast look at the difference
in temperatures now teens and 20s in
places like nashville louisville
pittsburgh but philadelphia is still
near 50 degrees and all that cold is
headed for the coast this system will be
finally gone by early tomorrow morning
but there's still a lot of snow freezing
rain and ice that's headed for new
england we've got high pressure over the
west beautiful and nice and clear for us
as we look for a sunny friday finish to
the week 57 that's a few degrees more
than yesterday and again mount
charleston very cold with a high of only
38 today and those north breezes will
pick up saturday and sunday we're
looking at 25 mile an hour winds through
the mountains so dress warm gloves make
sure the kids are all dressed warm if
you're headed up to do some hiking 60s
return for the weekend though a few
breezes on sunday but that won't stop
spring like 70s from showing up in next
week just a preview of spring with
mornings back in the 40s